[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous alors emmanuel macron qui lance aux
fleurs 1 c'est le nom poétique de sa
task force anti-fn news
oui oui on apprend par le site
spécialisé dans le renseignement a une
télé jones online qui mêle macron a
lancé cette fameuse task force contre la
désinformation
baptisé honfleur etc le secrétariat
général de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale qui est en train de
sélectionner quelles pourraient être les
acteurs privés qui seront responsables
de cette lutte contre la désinformation
alors le problème est ce qui peut
inquiéter
c'est pourquoi choisir de donner cette
mission d'intérêt général à des acteurs
privés est ce qu'il n'ya pas là des
risques tout simplement de conflit
d'intérêts on l'a déjà vu et comment se
fait-il que l'on choisit soudain c'est
cette lutte contre l'effet que nous
quels acteurs privés va être sélectionné
va-t-il s'agir par exemple du cabinet de
conseil mckinsey qui a déjà été choisi
par le gouvernement dans le cadre du
déroulement du plan vaccinal si c'est le
cas et si c'est mckeen's aigle il faut
savoir que cette entreprise a été payée
par le gouvernement saoudien en 2015
pour identifier et censurer des
opposants au régime
alors là on peut se poser la question du
choix politique de ses partenaires
privés et puis encore une fois entre les
cabinets de conseil et le pouvoir
beaucoup de porosité où certains hauts
cadres de mckinsey ont fait la campagne
d'e mails maquereau en 2017
et puis certains passent du cabinet de
conseil aux cabinets ministériels et
vice versa avec également les
plateformes qui n'hésite pas à recruter
dans le personnel politique
twitter qui récemment avait recruté une
attachée parlementaire la république en
marche et un ancien cadre de mckinsey
pour faire les acteurs publics alors
cette idée de tasses force
elle pose question mais elle s'inscrit
aussi dans la continuité puisque ce
gouvernement souhaite encadrer la
liberté de la presse et lutter contre la
désinformation il ya déjà eu la loi via
vous vous rappelez qui a été retoquée
par le conseil constitutionnel qui le
souhaitait lutter contre les discours de
n en ligne avant cela il y avait l'idée
d'un conseil de déontologie de la
profession de journaliste qui avait été
rejeté par l'ensemble de la profession
et puis via le cadre de la loi sécurité
globale on voit que cette fois ci la
majorité veut un peu attaqué la loi 10
181 qui est le fondement de la liberté
de la presse donc vraiment à suivre de
près cette commission fleurs est en
marche se mettent aussi en ordre de
marche pour 2022 avec une task force sur
les réseaux sociaux et de nouveaux
visages de nouveaux porte parole dans
les médias notamment
oui on a vu la nomination de deux
nouvelles porte parole féminine qui sont
partout présentes en compagnie des
ministres autorisés à importer les
éléments de langage quotidien sur les
plateaux des matinales
c'est là une façon de reprendre la main
sur le discours politique avec en plus
l'arrivée de nombreux militants
numérique sur les réseaux sociaux en
préparation bien évidemment de la
campagne de 2022 et là encore sur les
réseaux sociaux on peut se poser la
question
on a vu twitter censurer le compte du
président américain donald trump et de
nombreux de ses supporters et ça sans
vergogne de manière totalement orientée
en disant que c'était pour le bien de la
démocratie et récemment facebook autre
réseau social qui lui a dit petit à
petit un vbi 10 et les contenus
politiques dans les fid dans les
actualités des utilisateurs en tant que
sans doute les utilisateurs de facebook
ne sont pas là pour la politique mais
plutôt pour les vidéos de panda ou de
chatons donc de quoi dépolitiser le
débat ou plutôt plus graves
privatiser le débat démocratique le
prendre en otage d'une certaine façon
parce que ce sont là les patrons de
l'inter de certains réseaux sociaux qui
sont des enclos numérique qui décide
via les algorithmes qui peut être vue
qui ne peut pas être vu et ça va au delà
on a vu de la censure de compte
politique par exemple sur le réseau
twitter un compte qui s'appelle anonyme
citoyens qui partagent et de nombreuses
vidéos des manifestations contre les
mesures liberticides dans le cadre du
coc vide et bien ce compte a été censuré
par twitter et continue d'être censuré
dans ses comptes de soutien et et
facebook encore une fois qu'il sent sur
certains comptes politiques sans plus
d'explications disant qu' ils sont
contraires aux règles de la communauté
mais il ya des lois et des lois qui
encadrent le débat politique notamment
la pluralité des paroles politiques
donc je ne vois pas comment faire
campagne en 2022 dans le cadre d'une
privatisation du débat par ces
plateformes
il ya là un vrai danger démocratique et
nous devons être extrêmement vigilants
alors est-ce à dire avec sic un an et
quatre mois de la présidentielle
emmanuel macron est déjà en campagne
alors disons que le président se montre
prudent et s'il est en campagne s'est
discrètement tout ce qu'il fait et toute
son énergie est concentrée aujourd'hui à
ne pas être le seul responsable des
fiascos à répétition dans le cadre de la
gestion de la crise du coc vide fiasco
des masques fiasco du déconfinement
fiasco des tests fiasco du nombre de
doses de vaccins qui viennent à manquer
pour là il ya des fusibles
le professeur salomon olivier ferrand et
d'autre l'idée c'est de dire qu'il n'est
pas responsable
emmanuel macron se veut une figure
rassembleuse faire que tous les français
travaillent ensemble à contre cette
crise sanitaire
alors que dans le même temps et bien son
gouvernement par le biais du ministre de
l'intérieur verbalisent les
automobilistes qui sont en retard après
18 heures ou bien les français qui font
des courses après 18 heures donc on est
en train de diviser tandis que lui
rassemble mais personne n'est dupe que
qui décide qui est l'arbitré final dans
les conseils de défense liées à la crise
sanitaire c'est bien et mâcon qui fait
les choix en dernier donc il est en
train de se positionner de tempérer les
ardeurs de certains qui voudraient aussi
se présenter et puis s'il veut se
représenter en 2022 il faut que cette
gestion de crise soit inattaquable il
faut que son bilan soit présentable
on a vu que cette crise a coûté à donald
trump une élection
et pour ce faire et bien une façon sûre
de ne pas se faire censurer par les
réseaux sociaux c'est de se les mettre
dans la poche et s'assurer mais un
infaillible soutien pour 2022
et je vois pas comment faire si jamais
les algorithmes ont déjà choisi leur
candidat
et vous parlez des manuel da cruz sur le
front de la crise qu'il devra régler en
vue de la campagne présidentielle
à l'instant justement le chef de l'état
qui promet un vaccin pour tous les
français qui le souhaite d'ici la fin de
l'été merci alexis poulain
éditorialistes heures direct sur rt
france